I think maybe some women may find it  they may think it's unattractive to  another man to make more money or be  more successful so they may not want to  go for those job roles because they may  want the man to feel like the man in the  household and um yeah making a lot of  money is a skit as a woman and having  your own [ __ ] and not needing [ __ ] much  [ __ ]  um can be just hasn't can be very I've  been told  um scary or I think it's just the  attitude that comes with it I agree yeah  fairly you can come all sugary and sweet  with it and just kind of chill but some  women want to throw in the man's face  like look at me I'm a workout I make  money money me yeah like if you if  you're the Breadwinners is your money  his money can you make the financial  decisions where's your money your money  um a few because like I said I but back  to my point before I trust men's  decision making